comment vous savez dans l'équipe on vous
aime plutôt beaucoup c'est pas la peine
de regarder par là ce sera là un parce
que là j'ai des vieux avec moi dans les
noms ligne dans l'émission c'est à dire
qu'ils sont tous en train de regarder la
mode ça l'est on dirait qu'ils regardent
le spectacle ils attendent le feu
d'artifice opus que ces balles ça sera
là donc c'est pas la peine un merci
messieurs merci les mecs qu'ils on
s'entend alors y'a que la vérité qui
compte on s'en rappelle dans les années
alors jean lartaut si vous avez plutôt
que des amis dans cette émission vous
aime bien en plus gérer pousserait dans
l'émission des daurades ans derrière le
poste jeudi soir fait également vous
allez revenir sur toute la carrière de
2,2 jean-marc l'annoncent était bien
invité mon meilleur ennemi et de revenir
sur une carrière complètement folle et
puis un peu le phénix coin et vous vous
adressiez jean-marc n aura qu est ce qui
s'est passé vous étiez c'était la guerre
ben j'ai eu en a mis plein la gueule
après l'arrêt de son émission sur nrj 12
comme quand même il est susceptible il
est hyper mal pris ce public le mieux
réguler ce qu'ils voient c'est parfois
le fil seront tous les coups en retour
il en a mis plein la tronche et un
moment donné c'est lui pour le coup qu'a
fait le premier pas il m'a invitée sur
europe 1 on s'est expliqué et depuis
voilà on s'est réconciliés parce qu'il
est intelligent aussi exactement et que
je me suis remise en question parce que
franchement j'avais été un peu neuneu
et puis vous aussi et tout va bien mais
ça n'empêche pas de dire quand je fais
du des trucs pourris et confus aussi des
trucs bien oui parce qu'il ya des
techniciens en fait qu'est s'est dotée
depuis tout à l'heure alors je vous
explique ce qui se passe il ya détecté
sac et essayer de ne pas faire de bruit
les peaux
je vous explique installez le rideau des
gones a laissé direct les gars vous
embêter par est fatiguée elle souhaite
pas faire de bruit c'est bon les shérifs
jury fait le paquet pas on fait de la
télé on en direct vous inquiétez pas
merci ça tu me lemay là bas mon chéri
voilà très bien merci mon dieu mais
voilà vous allez avec le rideau s'est
passé à l'époque ils épousent des
ententes péta leur jeu blanc c'est à
l'école qu'on voulait pas faire de bruit
mais l'inquiétait pas alors vous êtes
aussi dans l'émission non mais je dis
c'est le meilleur des rats le poste
vraiment qu'on a fait depuis l'attaqué
vendée sur l'installation vendredi à
l'ailé chéri s'il vous plaît y'a que la
vérité qui compte
jean-marc on va relancer cette émission
qui était dans les années 2000
présentées par attac fontana exactement
pascal bataille et laurent fontaine ou
le contraire jean-marc il ya quelqu'un
qui va être derrière ce rideau et cette
personne souhaite vous dire quelque
chose
jean marc et vous chez vous pour que
vous trouviez qui est cette personne
voici un premier indice qui vous est
donnée par une personne qu'on est allé
tourner jean-marc ne pense pas qu'il
faut savoir enterré la hache de guerre
mais que ses pièces et demie alors pas
toujours pas toujours pas toujours non
je pense que de temps en temps il faut
on l'a fait avec enora como l'accès
expliqué mais il ya des gens qui vous
font beaucoup de mal avec qui il ne faut
pas toujours d'accord dit à camille
combal de se préparer plus tôt
sinon il ya toujours
jean-marc voici un deuxième indice
jean-marc sous les sunlights des
tropiques
l'amour se raconte en musique on a toute
la vie pour s'aimer en attendant viens
danser quand on sut à gilbert montagné
montagne et très bien vous entendez bien
ah ouais super bien il s'en passait bien
ouais mais là ça n'est pas gilbert
montana zut il ya une personne qui
souhaite vous parler
jean-marc cette personne écoutez bien on
a toute la nuit pour s'aimer cm du latin
et marc us vient danser c'est à dire que
cette personne est quelqu'un qui aime et
qui danse
il n'y a que deux personnes qui avec ti
dans ce cas bâlois loup et une deuxième
personne est cette personne
elle est derrière le rideau elle
souhaite vous parler
elle va vous parler vous nous direz
ensuite si vous souhaitez ouvrir le
rideau ou pas si vous souhaitez lui
fermer le rideau en pleine gueule fait
apparaître la personne une omission
tous ont reconnu gérard louvre
je
c'est bien sûr matthieu delormeau
matthieu delormeau carreaux joint à
l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste
matthieu delormeau qui était sur nrj12
qui faisait tellement vrai tellement
vrai également tellement fait les anges
et les gens se rebiffe
mathieu tout mignon il est tout heureux
d'être avec nous ni dans l'équipe et il
a mis son plus beau rouge à lèvres qu'on
peu fort vous parlez jean marc est ce
que vous souhaitez je sais qu'il ya eu
des frictions entre vous et voilà vous
avez de nombreuses frictions
d'ailleurs on vous appelle les
aquarelles va tout de même fait des
beaucoup est-ce que vous souhaitez
entendre mathieu ou pas du tout entendre
bien sûr entendre mathieu on va on
entend trop tôt non ça va normalement on
devrait déjà rendre au tél
le contraste les moteurs 47 histoire
mathieu mathieu vous m'entendez oui oui
c'est dingue parce que quand même on
feint duplex le gars est là c'est bien
mais on en n'est pas pour vous dire les
moyens techniques des pertes et se
rénergie 12 la maison dit le gars il est
là quoi vraiment immérité c'est pas
idéal c'est pas idée chez lui et mathieu
oui on vous entend pas est ce qu'on peut
s'il vous plaît mettre le micro de
mathieu pour qu'on l'entende
non mais ça changera rien ça c'est pas
la peine de vous toucher le téton nom
sonne et c'est bien parce qu'on aurait
dit on va durer longtemps mais n'ont
encore pas du tout alors mathieu oui
parler plus fort bah là je suis déjà à
fond ah oui vous m'entendez oui si on
plaît mettez moi un petit peu plus de
retour sur le plateau s'il ya quelqu'un
encore aux régies à 20h40
ça sera sympa ça ce qu'elles font parce
que ça chez la souris et serge tu peux
t'en occuper mon chéri tandem faire
chier le site matthieu delormeau mathieu
comment ça se passe avec jean-marc bas
mais bien ça se passait mal jusqu'à
présent ça se passe moyen jusqu'à
présent parce que pas
voilà chaque jour on va dire il ment
mais une petite dans la tranche mais
vous n'avez pas été sympa avec lui aussi
il paraît sans doute
mathieu j'ai deux choses à vous dire à
vous avez préparé quelque chose et 2
vous êtes juste devant les toilettes
je lui dise voilà donc merci bravo bravo
aux équipes annoncées c'est bien mathieu
donc ça veut dire que j'ai vraiment hâte
de par alain richet pas loin mathieu
vous avez quelque chose à dire à jean
marc jean-marc soit vous écouter avant
que vous ne lisiez quelque chose valérie
musique suspect merci en effet matthew
riddle on rigole mais si sérieux et
alors allez-y matthew alors jean marc
quand je savais que j'allais devoir
exane être un petit peu ému et j'avais
peur de perdre mes mots j'ai préféré et
écrire un petit mot en l'occurrence un
poème ça s'appelle l'oeuvre de l'amour
alors mathieu avant avant que vous
confiez votre problème on peut savoir
vous avez démarré ensemble tous les deux
ah oui il ya dix ans c'est vous qui
l'avait engagé je l'engagé sur europe 1
et puis ensuite j'ai engagé sur direct 8
où il était rédacteur en chef de
l'émission et il est à l'antenne
également tout donné ah non mais ça
c'est à lui de le dire mais il est aussi
vous a donné beaucoup puisque je vous
rappelle il travaillait d'arrache-pied
ouais c'est quoi le titre du poème
l'oeuf de l'amour l'offre de l'amour une
spéciale offre aujourd'hui alors
j'allais jean-marc tel le blanc et le
jaune d'oeuf le cuisinier de la vie nous
a séparés la tête
nous sommes partis tous deux chacun de
notre côté je suis le jaune de l'amitié
indispensable à la mayonnaise
et toi le blanc de la pureté que l'on
aime monter en neige
est-ce qu'on peut respecter le travail
de l'artiste n'était pas c'est pas
supposé être drôle aujourd'hui jean-marc
je te propose à nouveau de formèrent une
famille et que l'on recolle ensemble les
morceaux de la coquille voilà maintenant
le rideau est entre tes mains
l'eau
thales
jean marc gilly venir avec moi j'en
venais passer par là donnez moi votre
voix jean marc c'est dur et nous allons
partir tous les deux donc pas sur la
route de memphis sur la route de
l'amitié
bon je reste là 2010 je me dis alors
est-ce qu'on peut pas fermer
complètement le rideau ça coûtait plus
cher qu'à il est très réussie ce rythme
vraiment jean marc et vous mettre là
vous allez vous mettre ici jours à venir
je vais m y remarque la fois il y à la
personne que vous venez de voir le poète
danseurs matthieu delormeau qui est
juste derrière
alors soit vous ouvrez le rideau jean
marc et vous ferez tous les deux la
danse de l'amitié la de leurs modèles
et d'ailleurs je marque je sais que la
danse ça vous connaît que ça puisque
avant le gong preniez votre décision
jean marc j'ai retrouvé des images de
vous non et j'espère qu'il y encore de
la place pour l'année prochaine dans
danse avec les stars n'ont regardé
jobs et sa région
bye bye bye
arriva
oui qu'elles sont jolies les filles
live
alors
la tête avant j'oublie toujours que
c'est filmé europe 1 c'est ça me promène
aussi mais s'il avait ici aussi il
oublie que c'est filmé jean marc c'est
vous qui allez prendre votre décision
est de suspense est-ce que vous ouvrez
le rideau à delormeau ou est-ce que vous
fermez le rideau au vieux mathieu
thermale séduction très dur quand vous
regardez comme ça et vous me dites c'est
dur vous me faites peur je comprends
votre marché c'est que ces décisions
dures
j'aurai quelque chose à faire ou se
faire un nom reste rideau à calais comme
ceux ci n'ont même pas pensé
je verrai ce rideau ce rideau ce voile
le voile de l'amour le voile de la vie
levée des vies écoute maman et près de
toi écoute j'ai été très touché par le
poème niveau l'oeuf le jeune leblanc
mais je crois qu'ils doivent pas se
mélanger on souhaite le jaune et blanc
jean marc est ce que matthieu delormeau
et jean marc morandini ne doivent-ils
pas faire une omelette
regardez l'ascension de marine à quai
vous n'avez pas de dire non franchement
il a le droit de dire non je voulais
voir ce père je pense que je veux rester
honnête avec moi car je restais honnête
avec ce que je pense
d'accord donc vous n'ouvrez pas le
résoudre en pas le rideau mais attendez
c'est son choix
c'est son choix alors été dur
honnêtement je peux jouer mathieu jeu tu
adorais est ou non mais ils ne peuvent
pourquoi alors c'est pas non mais il est
bien placé bien classés je me trouve
battus en fait qu'est venu pour rien
j'espère que quartier
et
bach et mathieu en plus de regarder et
il a émis son plus beau kimono m2 fois
où les matches nuls dans sa gueule lance
pas quoi avait obtenu la danse et tout
ça est prévue qui me fait me riendeau à
la gueule quand même coûté mathieu ya
une voiture g7 qui va venir vous
chercher nos instincts cible également
voilà qui va vous emmener loin tout ça
vous revenez demain à l'émission hockey
j'en ai essayé ça va j'ai vu le gars va
bien vous avez bien fait non mais et
c'est le choix qu'ils ont marqué mais il
est honnête voilà on est c'est sûr mais
pas la rancune tenace vous savez j'ai
pas envie de jouer voilà ça s'est passé
plein de fois on a joué la
réconciliation ça c'est jamais bien
passé donc voilà c'est corey je vous
dire c'est comme moi avec l'équipe
voilà si j'avais les kidal rideau jaurès
et de rideaux fermés et terminé vers ses
jambes arquées bercy
ce que j'espère juste c'est que j'espère
juste en régie il a pris un cachet
mathieu béjot bien d'accord